pop
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour maïté un petit plat
simple probablement n'y a pas grande
chose sur ce plateau
qu'est-ce que vous avez l'intention de
faire tout simplement une poularde aux
vins d'alsace où il faut peut-être pas
grand-chose je vois pas grand chose mais
il faudrait bonne chose parce que faire
de bonnes choses parce qu'avec ça vous
allez voir ça va être délicieux
ou alors une poularde maïté l'amour
c'est un mystère pour moi quelle
différence entre la poule la poulette et
la poularde à ça c'est un petit peu
compliqué parce que je me suis trouvé
une fois nous et qui donc est logé à
grignols
c'est à dire que vous étiez en jardin la
limite des landes au galsi douala dans
le sud ouest
mais moi je quitte pas le sud-ouest
beaucoup je vais plus revivre à fait
vrai et puis il cette année c'est la
mode des poulardes et eux les éleveurs
de chapon ceux qui entendent échappant
de ça parce que c'est une poularde parce
qu une poularde en char pas une poularde
- mahmud chatterie parce que j'ai grossi
il peut être mais parce que ça on en
grossir mais on ne sait pas lire si vous
savez ce que c'est une poularde parce
que nous on sait ce que c'est un poulet
bon le poulet ya la poulette qui est
bien montée bien les açores et ses
soeurs après il ya le coq et il ya la
poule mais cette poularde elle vient
d'où voit ce qu'on est prêt bête où vous
vous allez me renseigner vous dire une
chose parce que vous avez la chance
d'être né dans le sud ouest
oui et connaître merveilleusement les
produits du sud ouest
mais moi qui malheureusement de cycle
parisienne j'ai toujours vu des
poulardes mais j'en ai jamais vu du sud
ouest
ou alors vous savez pourquoi il ya des
poulardes en bresse qui sont magnifiques
se spécialise dans la balance et qui n'y
en a pas dans le sud-ouest alors
pourquoi venez nous instruire et l'étude
rire alors pour cette poule ardouvin
d'alsace qu'est ce qu'il vous faut
il nous faut des vins d'alsace il est
évidemment du père et du laurier du
persil de l'oignon de l'ail des
champignons et puis ça c'est pour
d'autres recettes c'est-à-dire des
pommes de défendre de terre des noix de
muscade et de gruyère est ce que ce sera
cette seconde recette une galette de
pommes de terre aux propagé au lard dans
une petite entrée assez consistante
comme invitiez encore et bien alors
notre boulet notre poule est et de la
ventrèche bien entendu puisqu'il faut de
lardons
quelle recette commençons nous par la
poulette par la peau l'auteur vous la
découpe et oui vous l'achetez sa tête ou
parle pas de la nettoyer après oui je
vais la plume et jouez bien dans les
foyers vous allez voir dans la soupe
pour le bouillon un bon potage et là il
faut jamais coupé ça au choix parce
qu'il n'ya rien depuis villers poulet
quand la pâte est coupée ou un choix
vous a bien raison c'est par oui bon
alors les halons ils vont aussi aller
dans la soupe ça bien sûr que non alors
là nous avons une superbe cuif a soupesé
leurs est ce que vous écoutez les
parties n'avaient pas trouvé
et voilà au couteau c'est facile d'entre
eux aient fait ça combien de fois des
milliers de fois dans votre vie
quel est ce que vous croyez que vous
allez couper votre premier problème t
aimais pas très jeune mais parce que ma
mère nous faisait tous et nos parents
ont touché par la cuisine de nous ah oui
alors fois très jeunes contrairement à
ce qu'on croit j'ai appris depuis
pour c'est pas difficile il faut pas
avoir le bac si adam peu d'idées dessous
d'idées et puis ça y est les
articulations sont toujours les mêmes
ouais va regarder ça s'est passé en
femme
c'est une jeune ne pouvait bien attendre
à ça je trouve quand même oui mais c'est
alors la regarder comment on fait donc
toc et nous on ouvre la carcasse vous
l'aviez vider avons pas non c'est pas
vrai vous lie à vers le ciel à à berlin
la ville rebelle faudra nettoyer alors
hop promet deux côtés on finira après
parce que le ciel ça donnera mais voilà
on va mettre en avant des morceaux
nobles
voilà là dans la cocotte vous avez
munichois de la graisse de canard je
pense son jeu paraît toujours pareil on
joue pareil ça c'est des morceaux nobles
de la cocotte
voilà de la poulette
et on va bien se dit çà des deux côtés
avec du sel et du poivre de soucis
l'agent qui n'enchante il en eurocoupe
comme ça le bluetooth épisode de la
centenaire et voilà et après on va le
sortir ou le fait qu'un pays risque qui
peut saisir pour changer de couleur
maintenant pour que ça donne un petit
peu de chiffres ni de goût à la grèce la
voilà allez en sortir
rené bon pourquoi pas ce que ça donne ça
largement le temps de fuir après
largement magna dans le vert et dans
toute la sauce apple ont dit non non non
mais ça donne un petit peu de chance
inouïe
on va se rattraper vous inquiétez pas
les bras voilà bon et dans ce petit film
en salle à côté rue de l'oignon je vais
mettre un oignon voilà et là il faut en
amont pour que il faut quand même c'est
rien de plus leur faire pareil que
l'avenir parce que si on met l'oignon le
juge l'oignon il va rester ou glam tout
vilain il sera pas joli
danic et là il va peut bien blu ray bd
bien dorés on va l'attendre dix minutes
on passe et on peut dire que nos oignons
ils ont rudement changé d'aspect sa
superbe
ils ont réduit ça peut pas dire le
contraire est là qu est ce que je la
connais j'ai fait revenir
faites cuire des champignons de paris
très bien on aurait pu prendre des
girolles ou autre chose selon ce qu'on
arrête ce qu'on a
lassé des champignons frais de paris
voilà alors que je me remets large là
dedans sans agresser quand même où il
avait dû saler poivrer toujours tout ce
qui nuit dans ce salez et poivrez
maintenant on le met alors et maintenant
les oignons les champignons le poulet
alors cliquer en réalité cruelle à peine
saisir dans les brasseries du tout le
talent à revendre la nature parce que
pour les sept hommes ont remis blier
je vais y mettre du laurier les gousses
d'ail temps maintenant là vous avez
aussi fait une raison pour t'avoir
bateau dans parce que sa puce truite
live oui il y en a vraiment besoin de
vous après dire d'un joker du goalard il
va devenir bien failli y en a c'est est
ce que tout bon
un peu de persil voilà le persil je vais
louper la évitant de mettre les que
parce que ça va la regarder ça ça va
bien donner grossièrement parce que ça
va être
puis après ça va créer un certain temps
vous amuser h et soeurs voilà ces deux
boulettes
cette boule ardila polar la rose et la
rose et de vert je vais remuer
je regarde si je t'oublie tous filles et
la voilà alors avec votre vin dont vous
nous avez dit que c'était jeune alsace
et en alsace du riesling ou 10 kg
l'autre ou du début d'hiver sur le très
bon vin celui-là fait de riesling je
crois là et vous laissez mijoter ça
pendant 45 minutes il pendant ce temps
maïté être commencer la galette de
pommes de terre aux lardons et au
fromage
il faut passer la votation la moulinette
l'âge évidence à chauffer bon et alors
vous allez faire revenir ces petits
lardons on imagine alors comme ça très
bien c'est bon elle est validée dans ses
bons et ça va donner un goût la voilà ça
sûrement vous expliquer pourquoi vous
cacher on peut pas mettre la balle voir
après savoir pourquoi quand on sera le
flat on va se rendre compte qu'il faut
que ce sera très simple est maintenant
validé fois mon moulin oui et pendant
que ça veut dire on va s'occuper d'un
rap et les pommes de terre
vous en avez rappelé à peu près combien
pour un kilo à peu près à peu près voilà
les liens avec les gros trous de
l'ariana et ensuite et lardons qu'est-ce
qu'on en fait et là bas ils sont bien
vous donner un saladier
oui je vais mettre ces lardons blanc un
poil attentes en prenant bien soin de
laisser le jus dans la poêle
oui
alors je pousse la poêle bernois enlevé
le jul ces injures voilà et ensuite
et ensuite on va continuer à limiter mes
pommes de terre une bonne partie des
pommes de terre ne sais pas si tout
tiendra dans la poêle enfin vous allez
voir ça alors bien sûr vous allez
j'imagine les saler poivrer
toujours pareil est-ce qu'il faut leur
ajouter quelque chose en plus bien sûr
voilà alors je vais y grimper rappeler
encore et de muscade et merveilleux on
voit là le persil donna je lui achète
grossièrement ce persil et savent
accueillir tout doucement gentiment pas
d'ailleurs fait remarquer le président
le décida bon mais on n'en veut pas
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas contre la
manger me wade n'en est pas là vous ont
été généreusement fait d'avoir à cuire
oui je vais commencer à dresser le flare
d'aller voir
alors je vous passe je porte cette
terrible que vous avez prévu pour ça oui
et qu'est ce que vous allez mettre
dedans sans tenir de lardons un petit
grain la piste le fond de la voilà la
moitié ça fait ça et ensuite on va voir
ce que vous allez mettre dessus les
blogs et hervé sur s'occupe maintenant
voilà
regardez ça n'avait la moitié était en
assez je vais les arranger avec la
fourchette bien les aînés à une petite
couche n'a ça s'est régalé et ça coûte
pas un rond
tap la très rustique très savants dans
sa vie gruyère bière n'est pas ce que
c'est beau rush pas de guyane c'est
quand même pas exagérer ghrib
et ensuite ensuite les ardeurs alors là
il ya un petit peu de jus et vous savez
on va pas les gaspiller
parce que ça va bien se mélanger
regardez moi ça c'est pas difficile à
faire pour les enfants et je suis sûr
que ça fait un repas je croyais que vous
allez nous faire une entrée mais je
crois quand même que c'est la principale
ans à une salade ont fait leur part que
ces nourrissons excellent là où nous
sommes je ne mange ça déjà c'est un plat
qui vous plaît à morcenx un moyen pour
le ter du jambon de voilà c'est pas le
plat qui devra mincir nécessairement
face à vous tiendra bien on perd c'est
trop tard maintenant
voilà encore un petit peu de fromage
râpé là et ensuite il n'y a plus qu'une
chose à faire on va le mettre au four
gratiné à groupe dépasse tout est cuit
bien sûr juste candide et c'est tout et
puis nous n'aurons plus qu'à présenter
les plats précaire de cette poule hard
comme elle est belle à petit simple et
joli très jolie la petite poulard d'où
la grosse boulette que l'on veut avec
une sauce au vin d'alsace les
champignons les lardons plein de choses
qui donnent un travail qu'on fait est
très bon et ça coûte pas cher alors le
harassé trop fort hier enfantin vous
rappeler quelques pommes de terre
quelques ardeurs h et du gruyère et
voilà et au fait cuire c'est pas bon ça
alors revoir et à bientôt
bon appétit à l'échelle de tout
[Musique]